with my clubs you can see the same
direction at the same time and also know
that keep a safe distance apart
throughout also the turn from the body
not just an hour and if you can't not to
pick it up yourselves
so here I'm breaking down the movement
into four key points you've got your
left
when you're happy you pull those more
key points just pick up some cups and
just do the same thing just go through
those four segments these four key
points quite fun so when you comfortable
with that and try and smooth out maybe
divide it into halves so you just do the
bond and then when you're comfortable
with that just do the full circle
directions
quickly show you a common mistake when
you don't keep your arms together you
can see this head don't revisit the four
key points second mistake is usually
comes there too heavily anyway just
swings you around like this which will
imbalance so the correct form will be to
keep your posture stable by keeping your
spine straight and to use it your answer
so we'll move on to a variation of the
same time same direction which is a
shorter rail you can see I'm taking the
club's behind to my head
same as before both are going at the
same time same direction so I'll have a
look at it again without clubs I'm using
some earphones and crops here if you
notice I'm still using the key points
here so I'm taking it to the left by
using this method it's ensuring that
your hands if I decide to be head rather
then
going over the top of the head so when
it comes to using clubs and help by
yourself so like before once you've got
that moogly try and smooth that out
obviously you don't need to use
headphones to get this I just find that
it keeps your hands a safe distance so
once you're aware that I need to move on
the clubs okay so do the same movement
break it down nature those key points
and then when you're happy with that you
can just try and do it more motion also
remember to do both sides left to right
and shower with one rotation just move
on to doing it continuously okay well
that's it for this video the next one
that we're doing will be same time
opposite direction if you've got any
questions just leave in the comments
below thanks for watching